[Musique]
viens voir en berne ces cadres n'est pas
mince apparaît deux secondes
pourquoi qu'est ce qu'il ya un pas il a
arrêté cabinet du médecin à temps
question affronter bourgoin gb qu'un
maire les enfants j'ai une nouvelle à
vous annoncer
j'ai abandonné mon cabinet je me suis
consacré uniquement à l'écriture le
maire voit pas j'ai rencontré une femme
qui trouve que j'ai un style qui n'est
pas sans rappeler tout le script et
l'ovale pour la première fois dans cette
feuille blanche 80 g je tremble dit m
montereau prat
ok c'est un grand malade serait le plus
grand psychanalyste du monde tremble
quand ils connaissent du monde ok tu te
prends tu es censé écrire une thèse en
psychiatrie et dupuy deux ans vous
n'avez aucun respect pour mon challenge
quoi c'est que j'ai perdu la femme de ma
vie quand même mais ce qui s'est passé
avec usain culte eux manquent
bon j'ai un petit frère de 13 ans
complètement alcoolique et c'est ce
qu'on va faire on va prendre un shoot la
10 minute et au bout du cinquième on va
en prendre à cinq minutes du madr a été
fort un peu comme comme footing comme
poutine wheeler russe natura tu veux
qu'on soit ensemble
yvan traverse un épisode compliqué sa
vie avec d'autres cancers
je n'ai pas de vous envoyer une lettre
de refus à mon père faisait pas censés
être amis
le roman de votre appel vous l'avez vu
si mauvais que ça voulait un café un
spot au secours
donc on écrit des poèmes et ont indiqué
qu'ils réclament qu'est ce qui vous
prend à tous les deux
[Musique]
on était venus l'écouter fils je pense
qu'on l'a non
[Musique]